uh yeah so did you see the I shall talk
about that later but dude how about the
fact that that you guys watching that
Aaron Hernandez doctor documentary on
Netflix
looks like Brendan Schaub right it's
crazy
looks like Brendan Shaw but like if
Brendan Schaub like kind of like well I
don't know if you cared about his
appearance less but he's also handsome I
must say he's less handsome than Brendan
Schaub he's probably both - probably
both the same um oh god there's a real
sociopath huh
I watched it people ruin [ __ ] by saying
oh it's [ __ ] amazing they just want
to be on the train it is good but the
third episode is the one that really is
good the first two episodes sure I'm
along for the ride but the third episode
is really what [ __ ] took it for me
like it's all about how he had a like a
you know the way the documentary did it
was like he couldn't live his real life
and it really bothered him and it was
like a cocktail of [ __ ] emotional
activity that just made him act like a
tough guy and kill people because he was
like a closeted homosexual and he
couldn't deal with it and apparently the
other dude that he killed was gonna out
him and so he killed him that's what the
the documentary made it made it kind of
seem makes it kind of seemed like which
is [ __ ] so wild I just like every now
and then I'll stop that I'll think about
like imagine killing someone like um I'm
telling you right now this is what I'm
telling you right now this is Chris
D'Elia and I know there's a pop comedy
podcast and I do lots of beat bits
some of them funny most of them that but
I'm telling you it neither you know more
than most American funny is in there but
like I'm saying is if if I'm ever
accused of killing someone I'm telling
you straight up I was framed okay
like for real if my Bloods at the scene
if their semen somewhere if some of my
hair's on a dress or caught in between
one of the [ __ ] doors someone put it
there okay
I didn't do it I'm not killing anyone
ever that's my promise I was framed not
saying I can't
your boys beefy right
your boys beef but dude I didn't do it
all right so I will fight it I will I
will
here's the other thing too they some
about like what was the one where he was
like I saw one of these documentaries
where the guy was like yeah I didn't do
it
and they kit and and they found out I
was innocent but something where it was
like they were gonna let me out but I
had to admit it that I did it but I
didn't want to was this the same
documentary or something
no it wasn't what does some other doctor
mean I was watching and he was like he
was like III have to admit it I have to
take the the plea but admit that I did
it and he was like I'm not doing that
because that will mean I was always a
convicted murderer and even though I'll
be out in the world
what the [ __ ] documentary was it it was
I can't remember what it was anyway I
must have seen it on Netflix or
something but he [ __ ] straight-up
said no I'm gonna go for broke and he
[ __ ] I see the guy's face
some of your listeners were look good no
it's not the staircase but he was like I
was his like I'm I'm I'm not gonna I'm
gonna go for broke and I don't want it
on my record so he [ __ ] he went to
trial I was like well if they offer me a
deal
Hey
thanks but thanks oh but you're a
convicted murderer okay okay but I'm
free it was like I'll never see my he
had a kid too was just a [ __ ] errand
no it wasn't on mixing up I see so many
these murder documentaries dude
I'm surprised I don't go to bed and just
dream of people killing me anyway I'm
sure people will tweet me and I won't
look at it but uh yeah this Aaron
Hernandez thing man I just I just like
imagine first of all how hard it is to
come out as gay but imagine doing it as
a football player and your whole life is
being manly and that's got to be so hard
my heart goes out to anybody coming out
of the closet especially if you have a
family that's not gonna accept you but
even if you do it's [ __ ] hard enough
word up to all my or if I was uh that
happy
Chet Hanks Big Ups tall me gays big ups
for me closeted gays boyish ah big up
Ptolemy's gays everybody hiding in the
closet hey move Big O they movie on the
area
big ups foot creaking that doorway out
and walking out big ups for moving
across to the side and walking our big
ups for coming out and [ __ ] guys in
Europe any area anyway uh yeah there's
so many murder documentaries is crazy I
got to do a that's what I got to do my
next special I know my I got another one
coming out soon but my next one I got to
do a murder documentary slash comedy
special that [ __ ] would bro I'll be
playing arenas and make Sebastian
Maniscalco look like he's playing up a
mic bro dad would I would [ __ ] but
boom yep I should just murdered a murder
documentary comedy special forget it
that's it flying private everywhere